wie kommen bei der airpower wir befinden
uns da bei den flugsimulatoren wir haben
einige unterschiedliche modelle bei uns
kann man einsteigen und dann haben wir
probieren wie fühlt sich sagen in einem
flugsimulator und in weiterer folge
möglicherweise auch in einem flugzeug
wir haben zusätzlich zu den
flugsimulatoren da auch die flieger
psychologie bei uns hier kann man
bereits probieren hätte man unter
umständen das zeug und die eigenschaften
für den beruf des piloten der pilotin
ich bin ein flop und pilot beim
österreichischen bundesheer und hinter
mir kann man sehen wir haben mehrere
simulatoren beim harris personal und
aufgebaut und unsere aufgabe unser ziel
da ist es dass wir die jungen leute die
gäste aus der herkommen sie betreuen wir
stehen daneben wir erklären alles und
wir schauen uns dann natürlich und wie
sich jemand im simulator an stellt also
konkret schon mal darauf die steuer
führung ist das rein völlig wie geht man
eventuell mit stress um als das werden
jetzt keine großen stressigen
situationen entstehen aber man kann
schon ein bisschen rausfiltern weil das
pflegen ist halt der multitasking
angelegenheit wie sich jemand den
flugzeug verhalten und wenn es passt
also wenn wir durch ein bisschen talent
erkennen dann schickt man die natürliche
weiterzufliegen psychologie wo madonna
festung machen kann wenn auch du
interesse hast an einer laufbahn beim
bundesheer zum beispiel bei den
luftstreitkräften als pilotin oder pilot
dann kommt zur airpower am freitag oder
am samstag nach zeltweg wir sind uns
hier